quelques pas hésitant dans un gaz a
étrangement calme
au petit matin peu après l'entrée en
vigueur du cessez-le-feu
hassan alayan et sa petite famille ont
remis le nez dehors
après être resté onze jours terry dans
cette école
le long chemin du retour à la maison est
l'occasion de constater les dégâts
l'intense campagne de bombardements de
l'armée israélienne a laissé des traces
d'après les autorités palestiniennes dix
sept mille logements ont été endommagés
mille complètement détruit et la maison
d'hassan n'a pas été épargné regardez
ces débris toute cette vitre cassée se
désole-t-il avant d'entreprendre de tout
nettoyer de tout réparer car la vie doit
continuer difficile cependant pour les
familles éplorées de tourner la page
les bombes israéliennes ont fait de 143
morts dont beaucoup de femmes et
d'enfants
autant de victimes salué comme des
martyrs par le hamas qui présente le
cessez-le-feu comme une victoire
stratégique de la résistance face à
l'occupant israélien
pas de géant dans l'histoire du conflit
selon le chef du hamas ismaël haniyeh
une victoire proclamée aussi par le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou affirme avoir atteint ses
objectifs en détruisant le réseau de
tunnels du ramasse et en tuant 25 de ses
hauts dirigeants
le camp israélien déplore quand même 12
morts et beaucoup de dégâts matériels et
la trêve reste fragile la situation très
tendue au moins d'une demi journée après
le cessez le feu
des affrontements ont à nouveau éclaté
aux manifestants palestiniens et
policiers israéliens des affrontements
sur l'esplanade des mosquées à jérusalem
après la prière du vendredi
comme ceux qui ont mis le feu aux
poudres il y à cela deux semaines
les bombes et les roquettes ont cédé la
place aux pierres aux gaz lacrymogènes
et aux balles de caoutchouc
mais l'attention et l'inimitié entre les
deux peuples n'a pas changé et si jean
françois bélanger radio-canada tel aviv